[Music]  this one can fellow that's the credit  you justly deserve direct like the juice  and rabbit must be eradicated it's only  the very first not bad you will win in  this class we will deal only with what  has been proven the existence of  molecules that's not who you brought as  mr. burdock such a charming dinner  companion to help you return sooner  rather than later estimate and a formula  of his time won't even know I'm gone  dear Carol banana I write and ask you to  share my feelings particular theorist  Marie she deserves more attention than I  have to give mother you know very well  that I have someone else now later  you're the love of my life at creature  it is a nasty little [ __ ] know which is  my wife it's very busy haha can't even  get a job there is a position I know of  at the Patent Office I'm a scientist  myself I'm better than a clerkship up to  the Patent Office Toronto  [Music]  Oh  [Music]